hi how's it going
so today Jenna and I planned on making
some videos but that hasn't really
happened yet I was so excited I bought
all my ingredients this morning at like
9 a.m. I was super pumped up I was like
Jen we're gonna make all these cooking
videos today and then that didn't happen
let me show you why usually it's my
fault I'm never ready on time and it
takes me forever to prepare but today
it's actually Jenna's fault
so it looks like I didn't it wasn't my
fault
have you lost your mind but where have I
lost my mind
no just download a titanfall the tech
test said I play a little bit of that I
was playing call of duty earlier and I
was just not doing very well so I think
it's really confusing when I'm at my
desk is this I've got a keyboard for my
Mac keyboard for my PC so I just switch
between the two here PC let's try out
titanfall shall we
I forgot I wanted to make myself a hot
chocolate but instead I grabbed my
camera and started vlogging instead
clean the kitchen today did a little
reorganization any time I go to make a
cake I end up not having enough cake
making ingredients so I've made sure
that now anytime I want to make a video
especially a baking video I've got all
of the necessary ingredients readily
available accessible here if Jenna wants
to make a cake she can make a cake if
mat let's make a cake he can make a cake
if anybody wants to make a cake you can
make a cake was it's right here let's
make our hot chocolate
we're not boiling anything we're using a
microwave I would just like to also
state that I bought this milk today
using Amazon I've hit a new low guys I
hit an all-new low it's not that new but
it's the truth
I got myself a few weeks ago that I was
gonna stop drinking dairy but here we
are
three tablespoons tablespoon where's the
tablespoon at third table isn't spoiled
do you get spoiled cuz I think I've had
you for a long time one oh my goodness
gracious
I thought not everywhere little chunky
this is lukewarm chocolate
we gotta put you back in buddy would you
give her two minutes I just looked up I
I have hopped away for it
oh I'm making hot chocolate
longing yes this was gonna be a but I
drink while I play titanfall we take the
dog for a walk put any defeating fits me
he just got back from our walk and
Maddie scooted his butt on the brand-new
kitchen rug and guess what he left a
nice turn on me please don't do it again
please don't do it again don't step in
it well now I got clean enough then last
long sorry bro what are you doing you
know what you're doing wrong
Oh God play titanfall just download this
it's Sunday and the Alpha tech test
that's probably gonna be ending in a few
hours and I've only played two games so
that's unfortunate
oh god get away get my girl god I gotta
get out of here well now that I'm fully
healed I'm ready to kill Titan culty was
really fun
oh man I was trying to convince Jenna to
play it but she's a little bit busy
I by camouflaging let me walk tired it's
okay hey you guess what what I took a
bite of the Cheesecake it was good well
I got the cheesecake not necessarily eat
it just for a simple bite and you did
take a simple bite maybe I'll take a
simple bite as well hey Doc hi babe I
mean to be fair it's Sunday so you know
it's supposed to be like a day off being
a youtuber you don't actually really
have days off and you can have them but
not really I'll make it simple bite the
bad part is you don't have a day off but
the good part is most of us really enjoy
our job so that's great holy crap
I shouldn't have ordered this I did know
so it's kind of funny because I was just
talking to you guys I think in a
previous clip about how I was like oh
look I get so confused because I used
one monitor and then I decided you know
what I'm getting sick of that and now I
switch back to having two monitors so
this is my PlayStation an Xbox this is
my PC but I need a longer HDMI cable so
I can't even use the PC and this is the
Mac and this is Jenna Jen what did you
do today poor Jenna wasn't feeling well
today so she just kind of didn't do much
of anything but that's alright to be
fair office is messy mentally I prepped
all my stuff today too so I'll be ready
for tomorrow as well we've got a lot of
stuff coming up lots of fun videos we
want to know what you guys want to see
us do I would think you'd be fun to do
some like Sister Sister challenges like
miiverse you like doing something like
what that's the problem who's Jenna's
like better it pretty much everything to
me so you wanna 1v1 me in Call of Duty
I know because Mac destroyed me but it's
okay okay we know what this vlog is
basically problematic probably not the
worst vlog in the world it's definitely
not the best vlog in the world but I
think I'm doing Veda are you
continue this video tomorrow nope if you
want a video every day or a vlog every
day sometimes the video that you're
gonna get is not going to be the best of
the best so yeah bye huh no and then I
freakin posted like - every day last
week I'm exhausted
bye guys we're going to do a taste test
of Swedish Fish Oreos I don't even know
how you put Swedish fish flavor into it